hey guys in this video I'm going to talk
about leaky gut IBS
Crohn's and vitamin deficiency what
happens is that a lot of people get
damaged in their intestines from
antibiotics from viruses from certain
microbes and the little tiny hairs or
cilia or roots in your intestine become
damaged to the point where you don't
absorb like you did anymore so like in a
little plant that has the roots your
intestines are the roots just like a
plant that absorb the nutrients so one
of the biggest things that doesn't go in
is it something called bile B I le
that's like the detergent that helps
dissolve grease and pull it pulls in fat
soluble vitamins so if you're consuming
food and the bile gets released and it
doesn't get absorbed in the small
intestine but later down in the chain of
intestines because you have like 33 feet
of intestines so let's say it finally
gets absorbed way down there that can be
the wrong place to be absorbed and it
can create a problem like an excessive
laxative in that you have diarrhea
bloating cramping because the bile can
even act as a toxic thing and normally
you would absorb reabsorb about 95% of
all your bile okay and it goes right
back to the liver to the lymphatics and
then it recycles well with these
conditions you will be losing all your
bio so it's going to be point where you
have too much bile and then you don't
hardly have any at all so you can
fluctuate between constipation and
diarrhea all the time so there's a
couple things that you need to know
about not having bile number one that's
when you start having vitamin
deficiencies so all the vitamin
deficiencies of vitamin A would be
vision problems at night skin problems
sinus issues all the inner skin like
your immune system you're going to have
those despite consuming vitamin A
products because you don't have the bile
because the intestine is damaged this is
just a this is a big common cause of a
lot of vitamin deficiencies and then you
have vitamin E that's good for the
art it's good for hormones it's good for
skin so all of a sudden you have all
this dry skin and you wondering where
that came from then you have vitamin D
vitamin D helps the absorption of
calcium and magnesium by 20% in the
small intestine well if it's damaged if
the lining of your intestine is damaged
you're not going to pull in that vitamin
D so right there there goes the immune
system there goes the calcium there goes
the minerals you can't pull these things
in and you can't sleep it leads it to a
cascade of issues so one of the remedies
for the for these conditions is high
amounts of vitamin D if you can absorb
them then you have k1 and k2 those are
involved with clotting and k2 is
involved with the mobilization of
calcium out of the arteries so again if
you can't absorb those those you can
have a lot of problems with the blood
pressure heart problems arthritis
bursitis things like that okay so that's
another cause of vitamin deficiency
despite you eating them so here's what
you have to do you have to heal the
intestinal wall so you can have to avoid
a couple things of course you're gonna
have to avoid the most obvious thing
which is gluten okay you have to avoid
in fact avoid all grains if you have
Nicky got IBS or Crohn's and you're
still doing grains that is a huge
problem for you so I mean if we just
eliminate grains and even including
gluten or not probably a lot of your
problems will clear right up dairy if
you have these issues going to have
allergies to dairy so just cut the dairy
out you can't do cheese you can't do
milk so those two things are the
no-brainer of course also what comes
with that with the breads the pasta
cereal crackers biscuits all that and
the sugar so if we eliminate that that's
good but there's things that you can do
bone broth is a really good healer
because it's loaded with the glutamine
which is actually heals the lining of
the intestine you can take also a good
probiotic sometimes some of these
probiotics are too strong and they can
create a war and more of a detox so you
might want to start off slowly I like a
microbe called effective microbes and
I'll put
down below you can get it on Amazon or
another website but in fact microbes are
a nice blend of a lot of different
microbes that all work synergistically
cabbage is one of the vegetables that
are it's really loaded without glutamine
and it's good for officers and you can
do cabbage juice that's a real good
healer of the intestines cabbage is good
for heartburn you can take it in many
different forms you can cook it steam it
you can eat it raw but you may have a
problem with it raw so you might have to
steam it and that includes avoiding too
many foods with too many fibers too
because fiber could irritate and
overwhelm the microbes so this whole
thing with you even doing a kale shake
blended could be a problem you might not
be able to do that because you don't
have the microbes yet to be able to pull
it off pickle juice seems to be a real
safe thing good for the intestines
anything with lactic acid like kombucha
tea would be good episode of vinegar
would be good for some people ghee is
clarified butter that's also good if
it's grass-fed that has some fat soluble
vitamins especially vitamin A because
what we don't want to do we don't want
to avoid too many vital vitamins because
since you're deficient in these
nutrients you're going to have to
consume them in larger amounts for
something to go in there I mean we're
not going to just avoid those nutrients
so we have to put them in somehow so
then in green juices that will provide
chlorophyll to help heal the inner skin
the wheatgrass juice is the best because
it has a certain hormonal growth factor
in there that's really beneficial to
damaged skin and we all the inside of
our intestines are basically kind of a
skin it's an inner skin so that would be
really good to clean and heal the
intestines okay so anyway so that's the
summary of that and if you have these
conditions it could be why you're
deficient in these nutrients all right
thank you so much for watching